Next we turn to the page fault and ask the
question: What happens when an application requests a virtual address
that's not mapped to physical memory, but is somewhere on
disk? I'll represent a user's process like so and at
some point, he uses a virtual memory address that's not
actually mapped to physical memory at the moment. Yikes! Actually
it's not that big a deal. An exception is raised,
which sets the running process back to be ready to repeat
the instruction that created the, the fault. Meanwhile,
the operating systems page fault handler takes over to
address the problem. He checks to make sure the
request is actually valid and sends, sends a segfault
if it isn't. Then he loads the desired page
into memory, gets everything ready and then tells the
scheduler that the process is ready to resume. The
process will execute its memory move or read or
whatever it is again, and this time it will succeed because
the page has been loaded into memory and it can continue
running. That's the high-level picture. Let's talk a little bit more
about what the page fault handler does. So assuming that the
page we want really does reside on disk, the first thing
the page handler does is to find a physical page frame
in memory to load the data into. The best scenario is
that one is free. The handler keeps a list of free pages.
If this is not empty, then he can just pop one off.
Okay? And that makes us very happy. If he doesn't have a
free page, however, then he must choose a page for replacement. There
are many possible page replacement algorithms. We won't go into them here.
For our purposes, it suffices to say that a page handler will
pick a page that it doesn't think is likely to be used
soon. This page is saved to disk and then its physical memory
can store the page that was created by the page fault. So,
one way or another, we now have a free physical page in memory to which
we can write the data we need from disk. Then we update the process's page
table and any other data structures that
are page fault handler needs to keep track
of and then we're ready to restart the process and let it continue on to a